hence why the redness is leaking
through oh oh
oh no hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to amnesia
rebirth i just wanted to point out on
the screen here
uh that picture that was a little bit
odd
now is causing black veins to
creep up from the sand so oh and
uh is that just stitching that was
always there or is that i don't know
something about this is looking a little
veiny
anyway just wanted to point that out now
we're gonna scoot ahead into the game
well there it is again you can't deny
there's something very weird about that
picture
something very wrong about that picture
just inherently it's
it's a little odd why is a kid just
eating a can of beans what's with the
goop on the can all right so we last
left off uh falling out of the
sand hole and there's still sand poking
through
um but hopefully this isn't going to be
a horrible alien ship that we're going
to die
upon which seems like an
interesting possibility
hey wow
yep that seems pretty bad um
yeah pretty bad pretty bad okay
this kind of looks uh baby you lie
laughing
hey baby you alive
but at least you're still with me yeah
i'm still here
i'm staying all right yeah me too
i am also glad that miami is it
confusing me to play in both the mom and
the baby i don't know
i don't think i can just pick one oh
yeah these weird closets
alien closets you can tell they're
aliens because
they're alien i mean is it really aliens
or this is just some sort of offshoot of
human
they've got oil which is strange i don't
know why
they have oil but they have oil which is
good because i'm going to steal
it but i guess it's not stealing if it's
just left here abandoned
are all the aliens here dead or
something either the well was very deep
or she fell very slowly for she had
plenty of time as she went down to look
about
her and to wonder what was going to
happen next
okay what are you reading i don't know
alice in wonderland something like that
nomad oh little one
[Laughter]
i wonder why we're in a different plane
of existence
oh my god yeah absolutely yeah i'm glad
me i'm here um here
we here m2 i don't know why i'm getting
a little soma vibes
maybe just the blue something about the
blue really makes it feel like it well
that looks like a human
okay am i mistaken there's dick and
balls so
that looks like a heart right there
looks like some sort of a kidneys
skeleton looks about human-esque
this look
okay mommy it looks pretty humonesque
oh hey that's a nice suit of armor
can i have it from the oasis uh yeah
sure uh sure something
circled here and there i don't know what
any of this mean it's almost as if i
can't read it
ah this night oh
under the sign of banu of the fourth
rise at the eighth calling i
atari make this record as tamako directs
i have compared the most ancient of our
records of the empress's malady with the
newly taken samples in the earliest of
samples temaku was correct the nutritive
flow
of both organs of generativity were
intact albeit reduced and therefore they
would have been functional before the
spinal repair
however since the influx of vitae vitae
i remember something about vitae vitae
where was i the organs are now entirely
withered why has the substance
not reconstructed them did the
generative malady affect them
permanently before the treatment began
i have asked whether i should prepare a
report for the empress but tamaku
informs me that this is unnecessary
it is of course merely of alchemical
interest and no matter for concern
probably fine for she is eternal
in her name all right great
and boom i can read it uh under simon
banu third rise making the record i've
completed the comparison of the samples
of the empress and from the bones of her
mother blessed
it is clear now that both carried the
sickness although it did not manifest in
the forebears
while vitae is powerful enough to rebind
bone and sinew
without repeated application the health
again deteriorates a single dose is no
cure it merely drives back the decay of
time
the drives the decay back for a time
tamaku orders i test repeated
applications quantity insertion points
timing
in her name as in try an
insertion point in her name just shove
it in there
gotta cure her be boop no no beep boop
maybe i'm some kind of a vessel to heal
their empress
is that what i'm for is that why i'm
here
what the hell oh
weird okay why is this flowing that way
what is this kind of a relay thing
neat i don't know what that do
i find myself again confined a day
should not matter but each day feels
like waste
there is so much to do so much tamaku
tells me that now with vitae
i have forever but the people who depend
on me
do not there is always something
invasion rivalry sickness spaniary
i have my duty lexie and put on the
definition of what penury means
now they've found a way to stabilize the
disease
i should be ecstatic i should accept my
fate
and move on it is such a faint hope
that they can find any way to heal me
that they can find any way
to grant my dearest wish are you the one
that wanted a baby now
you are eternal says
now you need no air none of them
understand
this is not about politics or securing a
future
this is not for the empire this
is for me just for me
is the baby in my tum-tum
which is where the baby's located
everybody knows this this is a
scientific fact
is the baby in my tumtum a baby that you
guys put in me so that you could have
the baby it's technically your baby but
it's i'm a surrogate mother is that what
this is
is that the situation here i line i
leander septark of the unkindled
fortresses dispatch messengers to the
outer aisles under the guise of a trade
mission
despite our previous warning it is my
recommendation that we relocate
three fists of the second regiment to
the isles immediately
on the matter of the harvested stock it
has been suggested that with the new
chamber development
the need for such stock will diminish i
believe that is short-sighted
this new capacity surely means that we
are at the liberty to increase the
number of factories
with that we can vastly increase our
defense capabilities as well as increase
standards of living
across the empire this new expertise is
a gift
we would be wise to make use of it
instruct me great empress and i will
inform the council of your decision
in your name eternal
oh my gosh so much to read
[Music]
i can't read this i can't read this
it's not working it's broken this tablet
is garbage
okay so there must be something about
this
relay here kind of like this hop skip
and a jump relay is it because
does it not have like the right
resolution or something or
is that wrong oh my god oh my god i'm
sorry i didn't mean to oh my god
hello
[Music]
oh oh
put them in oh i see
so that they can all see it's some kind
of wireless power transmitter system oh
i see
i see i see wow
foolish me just a stupid human with
definitely not an alien baby
inside me right baby look at this place
where is this place
it isn't arabic
anything i recognize first luggage
hello hi it's me
how are you
okay so obviously i need to solve a
puzzle but i don't even know what the
puzzle is so how can i
solve it the answer is i can't there's
something missing there
these seem very broken uh these are
children's play things obviously i can
deduce that
oh it's right there okay so we got uh
fancy eyeglasses that you hold up at an
opera
wine glass cow with a beak okay yup easy
boinkus and if fluence
done slam dome baby
did i do it oh something needs to go in
there to
power it okay whatever
this thing this looks important this
definitely looks important i should
definitely get this thing
what is this thing though
[Music]
yep this goes in here i can already tell
remember my hush
i got it bam there's probably two
like paintball canisters that go in
there and then maybe a note telling me
what to do
under the sign of edu of the first rise
i key to make this record the
configuration of the new test gate has
been delayed by the failure and the
subsidiary node bihar you must complete
it on the next prize to do but prepare
the place of orbit and center select the
focusing symbols for the saline and
insert two full cells of vitae
remember tamaku's lessons power master
of the orbit is your focus and
discipline that will open the portal and
allow objects to be sent through
oh wow
ah like eternity oh
well well well looks like i
have an orb so it wasn't this thing this
is a lid i put a lid on there
i put a damn lid okay hey how you doing
hey baby you see this thing
we're cool right i'm wondering if i died
in that crash
that's a good thing to wonder because
you're still here
and it's sure as hell isn't heaven
yep sure it sure as hell isn't heaven
and
you know maybe this baby's hell but that
hasn't been proven yet
oh yeah i forgot about the triangulation
scoocher
the thing that's gonna zap power all the
way over to
other places
man this would have been annoying you
had to do this everywhere
uh all right maybe i gotta go around
i'm coming whoa nelly oh
shooty tooty yeah just gotta open it
yeah push it oh
shoot hey there's something down there
is that where all the vitae stored
there we go you got some vitae down
there all right so uh maybe i could
drag out a table put it on there maybe
we could put it on the window sill here
is that gonna work no
okay hold on let's go explore the rest
of this area
uh hello
uh so i can't go in there so the
question is just to open this door here
which won't take long because i'm
big smart and uh clearly oh
it's i just had to put it over there
uh love your son uh you know
windy is what it is
yeah it's fun is this like a living
breathing city
oh there was a white sun
at the great gate it tore the air and
the land
a corruption of living flesh crawls from
the hole in the world
and turns all to ash and rust the
control stones have turned against my
kindred
shaping them into floating wraiths of
nightmare the city falls
i am to blame my companions took my
formula some to use it to destroy the v
tie at the gate
others to infect the vitae pipelines and
end the suffering
the gate has indeed fallen but
catastrophically unleashing energies
beyond belief
still the factories scream we have
failed
in the worst of ways it is my duty to
stay at my post
to see if i can find means to end it i
have no choice but to use the vitae
an ocean holds the great empress to life
so omega portion will suffice for me
if any find this record know that i
was the traitor kita alchemist
apprentice to tamako forgive us our
folly
you know i will say this it may be just
an actor thing
but i've very rarely seen something in
sci-fi where there's a civilization that
has ended catastrophically
and the last will and testament of such
race ending
sounded horrifically like distraught oh
hey are you kita sorry i
uh i didn't mean it uh
you just hey do you need this
i'll wait until i do that
uh i could probably take that one but um
uh
yeah maybe i shouldn't just take things
willy nilly
uh i might have to take things
willy-nilly ooh what is that
experiments with the orbs summoned an
entity
a creature that scarred the world with
its passing
and wreaked utter destruction the scar
took the form of living pulsating flesh
i have studied the orb and i now know
why the scars appear
i believe i can make use of the same
perturbation
to achieve our own end that's always a
good chain of thoughts
when something goes into your world that
you transported from another dimension
and it only leaves death and destruction
in its wake
and transforms into giant pulsating
flesh the obvious course of action
is to do it again but harder that's
definitely it
wow and there it is
good stuff hmm i can't read that well
look at this memory blinks it has taken
me
many many rises in the gaps between my
work for tomoko but
finally it is done i have a formula
which is in sympathy with the pulse of
the all
i can provoke the symptoms of the red
flesh
and with it will come destruction
channeled through the vitae network
this might be the answer we seek sure
sounds like it definitely sounds like it
is this before or after everything fell
the crap because
if it's before then i wouldn't assume
you would be sad at all because it
really seems like
this is just poor planning on your part
anyway i need this boink
you're out of vitae uh excuse me
you're not using this are you chunk
thanks i need this
all right see you later keita um
and
oh maybe that wasn't cool for me to do
up
uh did i have to do the um
i'm guessing i had to because there were
two hmm
well if if if rumors told it seems like
he might have been a bit of a dick
anyway so
um
all right anyway i'm gonna turn a corner
on with like oh look vitae ah
all right i got what i needed some
blankets and
uh dwinkus and uh put the orb in the
oinkus and
splang doodle the fluence and uh
really crack yank the the
blankets we've got something wait wait
we got something over here
oh it's pointing to the big glowing
thing in the wall another that could be
our way out
yeah uh-huh that definitely is a way out
i just got to figure out how to put the
orb in the doodad put the orbit slam it
in slam it home put it on
put it in put it around put it in there
let me in there let me in there i'm a
baby
let me in there that's where i go here
there everywhere
okay oh
and yoink oh
oh and oops
can i have that back thank you
you could be a little faster
anywho
i know what i need to do now this is
gonna go over here
because it's gonna shoot into the other
room and open up the door from the other
side
and yoink blastums
kaboom send it boom
[Music]
did i hear something else there bro
nothing i need to worry about
[Music]
love me an orb you know alexander would
be really proud of me
smoke that's the town
and the doctor how can that be
how can that be everything's a mystery
nothing makes sense
oh my god oh
my god
oh do i need to run now whoa hey
all the red pulsating flash
oh yeah um uh there's nothing i need
right
right uh right
before i panic that's the same flesh and
pulsating stuff from
the original amnesia yeah that's a good
point but i got a funny feeling that
there's something else that i need here
but i just don't know what it is
yeah maybe not maybe not maybe not i'm
just gonna go for it screw it i'm going
through yeah
oh god it's dark oh that's because it's
clothing
and i can't see when it's loading okay
am i supposed to be somewhere oh yes i
am
hi it's me
markiplier
baby
maybe
maybe mama baby
maybe mama oh maybe
maybe maybe maybe maybe
baby baby i can't baby baby can't happen
baby
baby no baby baby
maybe maybe baby
hello baby hello baby
[Music]
i just can't play alice is gone
don't worry mama i'm here
well that's good that's very good
that's very good oh hi baby
um baby i can't look at my baby right
now so
uh pressing the baby button but it's not
baby ooh baby got bigger
maybe got bigger oh baby baby's getting
bigger
well that's what babies do hello baby
i don't know if i can birth you oh
[Music]
oh uh
baby's bigger uh wait hang on hold on a
second
uh no no no you're so much bigger
this can't be real wake up
wake up jesse oh god
oh god what am i going to do
something tells me it's going to be a
big baby
oh boy come on yep put yourself
together
i was a big baby when i was born makes
sense
baby oh [ __ ]
i'm i'm so heavy
yeah it seems like six months
more oh god
um well um
what if i get even bigger i mean if it's
six months
i'll try to hold on but this will be
difficult little one
damn these bones they're gonna be bones
everywhere
anyhoo well i still got my strength uh
at least i have that
as long as i have my my
strength i'll be fine just get these
rocks out of the way
this isn't a dream this really
isn't a dream yep uh
yep yeah just yep that's all i gotta say
all right any more please more than just
one more than one
fine oh are you
okay so we got some rocks here that does
not look like a way out
oh wait a minute oh yeah i have my
strengths
[Laughter]
ladder oh my god i thought i was gonna
fall and die
maybe it would have been a quick trip
yep note down there we go
oh that's dark oh that's very dark
smash priceless artifacts who needs them
who cares about him
oh it's a crypt
uh-huh okay
how much oil am i working with plenty
plenty of oil for now
second achievement yeah well you know
how it is
oh i don't want to go back yet
i just got here i gotta go
go back uh maybe it's like some
secret doodad they're like just
resources in here or something
no just nothing there's a whole lot of
nothing in here what's the point
unless it's a hidey hole might be a
hidey hole
i don't know i don't know sure
some red flesh here oh wow's right here
oh there's another one
hello
it's a whole lot of nothing
[Music]
weird
all right sure wonder who gave me this
thing
i like it like that
what laboratory the one wait the
laboratory of the aliens or the
laboratory of just
laboratoriums oh well hang on
there's another path over here maybe
wasn't there oh no
there's not well i guess i'm going over
here then
okay hey it's me again back here
back at it again with another universe i
wonder if there really have been like
secrets that i was supposed to
like pay attention to with this thing
out but i just haven't looked at
it's entirely possible
what happened oh what's happening
i don't know what happened
what happened i missed it it was all red
why
okay hi
hello hi
great good stuff what is this
fun stuff uh it's what they were talking
about in the letter and it's what was in
the other game way back when
oh my god
yeah it ain't pleasant i can tell you
that it ain't
pleasant oh oh goopy
baby you all right how about you knit my
bones maybe you want to knit my bones
for me okay bye
you're bigger you can knit bigger bow
okay so the lesson is don't touch the
red stuff
because it hurts and that's the end of
the story what's up here
secrets no no secrets someone just say
baby
i could have sworn i just heard the word
baby oh
god of course of course it's right there
in front of me but i can't have it
oh my god is anybody down here in the
midst
oh i see oh is that a crank
oh i thought i saw a crank frank would
have been cool
there's some cranks here and there hello
nah
so okay there there seems to be like
destabilized portions
which makes sense this whole thing is
kind of blending together
oh hello cool yeah
that's good hence why the redness is
leaking
through oh oh no
oh that's not good oh that's not good
yeah run yeah run run run and running is
good running is good i like running
bring it out bring it out bring it out
okay run run run run run run
oh that's lovely okay down yep down down
down is where we go
oh yeah
keep going down you know up in the
deserts where you don't want to be is
what i've discovered
okay keep going i think we're gonna need
more lamp oil
oh this is familiar this feels like
amnesia music come on
come on baby come on pedal those tiny
feet baby
i need all the power we can get reuse me
like a flintstone car
let's just keep going
oh there goes the legs baby fix the legs
i got failure on the leg systems
uh is this still after me i'm gonna
guess yes oh no
yep
oh yeah this is clap i'm so strong baby
with our powers combined ah we are
unbeatable
we're unbeatable baby
alice
ellis something's wrong with your eyes
huge dude oh
christ oh good i'm back in the
other world i don't know when that
happened but apparently i'm here
i did it maybe i don't know what i did
it's all a bunch of portals what was
alexander's uh
objective in the first game what was he
really trying to do oh
i guess i can't run as far
how did we get to this how did we get to
this you grew so fast
probably probably i'm gonna go with
probably
oh that's locked in place okay well
so they definitely don't line up so
there's gotta be way to like extend
these as opposed to turning them i'm not
certain it's how about this culture
really loves them some orbs
you know what i mean this door is stupid
okay that also does not move which is
fine i think it needs to be extended
into place which is cool uh
oh again little one see it's another
gateway i think
a portal right in that laboratory
big enough yeah us yes look
little one i think this is a way out of
here yes
i know it's crazy but can we get it
working
of course we can
of course we just need vitae
we just need the glorious power of vitae
boom looks like we don't have enough of
a tay this isn't working
yeah i gotta go get something apparently
um laden jar like vessel resembling
those in place in device in portal
chamber but spent broken relic age
unknown manufacturing quality
high as if welded or cast using advanced
modern industrial methods
spiral symbol on laden jar bank also
found on door near camp leading
to maize grid chambers below devices
powered by electric fluid
were some means of gathering electric
fluid yeah you're talking about vitae
yeah you're probably talking about
vitae yeah yeah yeah not many people
know about its big secret in the
industry
i know about it though cause i'm smart
big smarter i also got a big smart baby
if you didn't know big smart baby very
big very smart actually bigger than you
so don't even bother oh big baby just
slammed
i've damaged myself a lot but i don't
seem to have any sort of like
health repercussions where does this go
absolutely nowhere but it went literally
nowhere jump
all right there must be some vitae down
here are we actually on earth
hi nice balls all right see you dudes
uh hello
baby wow this looks nice
professor i believe this is only part of
a bigger construction the archives make
reference to this place as a gate but it
also talks of other gates
if i'm reading correctly there's a
symbol that reads as crops or harvest
perhaps it is related to the seed sure
but wasn't someone else
called crop harvest something like that
i was right
1839. is this when the original amnesia
it is a bitter pill a myth ray mithraem
and it in in it an orb and now my
daughter of an assistant has shattered
it
i have sent it and him to brandon
perhaps something may be salvaged so
what is left to me now there's a gate
here i have vitae but no orb
i have discovered nothing of what
brennenberg calls the traveler's locket
yet it is clear this place is part of
something greater these halls are not
the final resting place of their great
queen whatever the legends may
say this is merely a spoke on a wheel
what does the hub hold
what is with all the hubbub you may ask
this must be people that either worked
with or
knew alexander who may have been of the
species of these people over there you
know what i mean
a supposedly a map it's a map of puzzle
line them up and kaboobie booby ethereal
resonance chamber
tuning you got it oh
hello we need to get out of here soon
stop kicking
stop it hey mama's here
stop kicking this place is so strange
you on earth built it do you think i
don't know
dj khaled a full and accurate copy of
the symbols in your room with the
pillars is most important devote
yourself to it i wish it to be completed
by the time i rise tomorrow in
particular pay attention to the symbol i
have labeled as seed
i believe it to be the crystal orb that
i seek a clue to its whereabouts will
see you well rewarded
is this the assistant you just assigned
that broke the orb like an
idiot big dumb stupid couldn't even put
up his tent right
idiot uh hello
abdullah khalid will take on daniel's
duties
you are to commence excavation of the
side tunnels immediately break down the
roman walls if you must they are
irrelevant
anything older than roman investigate if
there are any more markings such as are
in the room with the cage
i wish to hear about them any records
carvings or signs that resemble an
amulet or bracelet
i wish to hear about them any round
stone of crystal do not touch it on pain
of death but summon me at once
yeah uh-huh daniel you say
the same daniel from the first game
very interesting very
interesting you know very interesting
okay there's a light shining over here
i'm gonna go here
first hello this is richards
he was here who's richard i don't
remember oh
followed harris insane i won't
i won't richard come back
richard rezard
[Applause]
they left us richard
and alex i
i don't remember why yeah i don't either
and frankly i don't even care it was
probably
stupid and there's probably his blood
that's what he gets that's what he
deserves
do i need to go get the orb i probably
don't you know what i mean
whoa i don't know if it's just like
every single tunnel down looks like the
original amnesia tunnel but this
very much looks like the original
amnesia tunnel
funky cool
oh hello baby how you doing all right
well it seems peaceful down here ah dang
it
hey whoa wait a minute
hey you can you stop eating in there
and help me out i need to get uh
some vitae you know how it is
you know you know all right cool see you
around
guys baby shush
to a gold mine to make it more efficient
alex sterling's family were paying i was
doing some drawings jonathan
he was the engineer oh my juice is good
i don't love this
i'm gonna guess not much uh pretty much
nothing
um in the face of certain death and doom
i'm gonna guess very little
uh so what do i do
found this a door to many worlds by t.a
herbert i'm busy forward as i write this
memoir the great endeavor is on the
verge of completion
that very threshold which has eluded the
members of our fellowship down to the
ages has
lies before me and i thirst and herbert
have the keys within my grasp to open it
what great beauties what bountious
paradises
may lie beyond the gate surely it will
lead to the arctic apes to the
megalithic structures in brazil
to anywhere within our realm yet we may
go further the evidence has been used
before our eyes since the days of adam i
used that example advisedly
for surely the story of adam is the
hebrew retelling of our first arrival
thrust out of that garden of eden
and into this harsh world beyond the
gate lies the garden the place of our
making
and i will be the first since adam too
uh-huh yeah go on tell me more
tell me more look at these dudes
[Applause]
yeah nice nice guys hey guys nice
um uh oh oh oh
oh oh oh ho ho hey hey ho ho ho
i did not see that even the music
decides to play because i looked in the
right direction okay
good for me good for me guys very good
for me actually
the best for me only the best for me
i have to say
oh i didn't know that was actually going
to open for some reason i didn't think
that i was actually going to open
oh my heart
i don't like the lines coming out of the
head of the bed there it's all not very
good
it's all not very good
got it okay what do we see here
[Music]
oh yeah looks fine
that looks good in fact actually it
looks good
oh
all right okay well this
is fancy oh someone's dead there
but why uh-huh so there was that passage
before that said something about the
garden of eden so
that's why all the aliens look human
because in this
universe humans came from another place
to here diagram on wall map
ley lines star chart position on radio
spectrum akin to wavelength up
hello
yes mean yes yes hello i'm here i'm here
i'm i'm trapped i'm in a tomb
unless we can get out of here speaking
of the moon must test
complete paths oh yeah sure
okay yeah yeah yeah sure yeah okay
that does look like a big thing and that
looks like a
big orb i love it oh fun
oh interesting oh this oh interesting oh
oh interesting ah okay so i need to
match up those do i you
wine and fancy glasses winky face
wine there's only one wine symbol and
it's right there
the other ones are all darkened out
[Music]
maybe i don't need to match those maybe
i don't know enough yet
[Music]
perhaps it was once a real person called
tin heenan a leader of her people if so
she is likely buried in the tower egg
tomb far above us
there are other much older stories that
have been conflated with hers
legends of the grey lady a goddess who
walks the desert
legends of a healer legends of an
empress i think these are ancient
memories of what truly happened in this
place
yeah i don't even know what the legends
are so i'm not sure how you would uh
expect me to know anything about that
hey how you doing dude
man you are so dead
my god you're dead you are just
dead stunningly dead
hey peekaboo oh what is my character's
name
tati tita
hello none of the doors work none of
these
alien weirdo doors work okay fine i'll
go through the door over this way if
that's what you really want
if that's no okay i guess i won't then i
guess i won't guess that's what i won't
do
guess me not do that guess i'm not gonna
do that
guess i'm not going to oh what i
probably need to do is i probably need
to
find the process of elimination kind of
get the
whoa hello weird
okay i see
wow okay so we got winky face
cow beak cow
okay what else could we do okay so it's
definitely not
wine glass wine glass is not in the
middle
because there's no way that wine glass
could be any of those
uh i bet it's not repeating patterns
let's go ahead and try
that i guess
oh this is stuck
okay so that's good it has to be winky
face first
because that's stuck i guess so it has
to be winky face
first oh it could be
[Music]
huh winky face cow wine glass right
that's what it could be
hmm
dang it all right winky face
glasses winky
that's no face that's no good
okay so there's only so many other
things it could be
the only other one i see that starts
with
that is winky glasses glasses
right maybe why do i always go the wrong
way
oh my god
bingo what is it then
diagram on wall this thing
oh oh my god i see it i see i don't know
why i didn't see it
okay right i i i didn't notice the
grooves in the pillars
oh that's what it meant oh my god of
course
so it must be that okay so that's what
that is that's what that must be
oh we've got a path and it even outlines
it okay so didn't i try that winky
moomoo
did i not try winky moomoo i thought i
tried it but i guess i didn't winky momo
gimme winky momo winky mobo
ah oh
wow oh wow
i guess that's what i guess yeah uh-huh
let's hope that's fixed
yeah uh-huh let's get out of here gang
uh
geez scoob we really oh baby can you
jesus are you gonna get a bigger baby
at least i'm not
that works for a boy or again
okay good yeah good good i'm gonna go
with good
i'm gonna go with good well you know if
humans came from this other world it's
technically not an
alien baby technically
technically
it's growing fast for a human baby but
you know
it's the empresses baby something like
that
something like that something like that
something like that
i'm a tinkerer i done did tinker
i tinkered with it all right let's
oh baby we're going to go home here
easy that's good
so easy yes
uh no
there's definitely something wrong here
yeah what's the deal
almost like i don't have vitae oh
what are you doing out of a lot who
knocked you out of alignment
oh oh oh not that one who the hell
i brought that into alignment the first
thing i did that was the first thing i
did when i walked in this room
all right let's get out of here excuse
wow oh oh
oh oh [ __ ] no
yeah looks pretty empty now well i'll
take this one for now because i know
there was a door that needed some vitae
to open it down here
so i guess i'll do exactly that i didn't
notice these before
alexander vaughn
brennenberg we were right zarzura is so
real
i took an orb from the shrine in the
salt mines but the shadow pursues
and i am trapped i will attempt the
crossing it is my only way out
record my name tell all it was herbert
who gave us new worlds to explore uh-huh
that thing is after me it has been
hunting me for days
but i keep out of its trail so i will
persevere
i can see a settlement at the edge of
the desert i'm getting closer
i can see it but it is not me it is
abdullah
through his eyes i see his mind i hear
confined to myself i see only death
dressed in the orbs darkest
shadow so the orb is uh not good
from what i'm picking up on this if i'm
reading the room correctly the orb is
uh not good nice balls uh and probably
should be avoided at all costs because
it creates this shadow and red flesh
you sure are taking this lightly this
whole other world business
skadoosh hi
you got any more of that
you got any more video around here
somewhere i really could use another
bottle
no they're fixing oh my god look at it
the demon kids in the back horrible
why are you crying horrible
anyway you got more of the vitae
[Music]
oh look it's a door that actually opens
wow
look at that it's a weird mixture of uh
technologies here almost like people
were looking at this
uh we cannot reach the device attempts
to break the metal have failed as it is
the same strange composition as the
laden jars
a thorough analysis is impossible until
we can get closer but my theory is that
the laden jars are containers for some
sort of energetic etheric fluid
and that the device in the room below is
some means of gathering such fluid to
fill those jars
what exactly it is drawn from is unclear
surely not simply the surrounding
atmosphere
it would require something with a great
deal more vitality i have sent the boy
rasheed
below with a paint pot and brush and
told him to mark any route he finds
clearly oh
i bet he's dead but hopefully he marked
some roots before he met his
untimely demise that would be
great keep me from getting lost
uh an empty jar do i need that
yep all empty no yes
what is that supposed to be i don't want
to know what that's supposed to be
i'll break your piss pot bam
hello khaled has excavated several more
laden jars which are fully energized
while it is clear that they are required
to power the portal device without
another war by
unwilling to waste them on a test
however i am now certain
the contents of these jars this
fluid-like energy is the vitae
of which alexander spoke yes because
he's from
the other world and he
was just trying to get back home
oh i see ah of course of course
yes of course such a lovely painted path
something's skittering
who said that
come on with your hands up blocked on
the other side of things i get it i get
it okay i see
i see i get it i get oh
i'm so strong i am like
ungodly strong i'm strong
even some might call strong oh were you
talking cause you're
dead so that'd be weird
alex sterling oh god oh god no
yeah well i would assume that just
everybody's dead follow her
save hank i'm going after richard
best of luck
so the real question is how did i end up
back
on the ship how did i end up back on
this ship
that's what i want to know how did i end
up whoa how did i end up back on this
ship
how did i end up back in the ship that's
the real question
that's the question how did i get all
the way i mean fine whatever
losing memory oh god kicking you know
what i'm going to assume that
something's going to come
i would never be able to survive because
i could never close my door fast enough
i feel a bit better how did i get to the
ship did i teleport
there wink
i knew when i first saw them sitting
beneath the trees in the hotel garden
richard's complaining about the coffee
wow this is some kind of super chess it
was in every look they shared
adorable under the sign
of aranga on the second rise at the
second calling i
karangi make this record we have
identified a fault in the revised layout
for the hunting ground gating system
where previously the harvesters
had leeway to stock the subjects for at
least 100 edar
the current configuration lowers that to
30 as the subjects simply panic
and stampede this does not give enough
time for an appropriate build-up of
harvestable energy within their systems
i recommend restoring the previous
configuration temporarily while we
re-evaluate
so recorded in her name eternal ah
interesting so here comes the truth
vitae is distilled fear
literally that seems to be what i'm
reading here they need to be
afraid enough for long enough to let the
vitae
build up in their system and that's what
this is and that's probably what that
represents
the things that hunt and then you
extract from them
hopefully it's more like milking it
and not like something else but
they extracted hunger
i've got the hunger i've never been
so hungry please i need delicious
food my hunger is unstoppable
i've never been so hungry
do you understand to my hunger oh don't
tell me i have to go
into the labyrinth i'm gonna have to go
into the labyrinth aren't i
oh my god why do i have to go into the
labyrinth i don't want to go into the
labyrinth
i don't want to go in oh no i don't want
to go
oh god i'm going into the labyrinth okay
good stellar good
good hopefully the kid
painted it oh no
oh no oh no hunger
it's got the hunger
never been so hungry come
come on uh
well interesting have you got to keep it
off of that
uh yep that's right okay
oh i see oh no
do i gotta move this onto the things i
don't know
i don't know what i'm doing i don't know
man i don't know
i can't even get it on there okay it
won't even work
uh i don't see any pain that kid was
useless
okay i'm in the main
oh no oh my god are you actually in here
ah why why what i didn't see anything
that guy's very dead
not now baby
so it is the distilled fear which makes
sense why it's like i can't get
fearful and i can't get angry
gods no
oh no no no no no no
hey wait you don't wanna you don't wanna
do anything like that
you don't wanna do that listen the
hunger
can't control you don't let the hunger
control you what are you doing
what is happening what is that okay okay
okay that's that can't be good
okay well all right i'm dying now
yes i'm tassie
hello i am
good question how can i live i was about
to beat your ass into the ground so
you're lucky you
mo okay you're lucky you backed off
oh well i just can't get out of here
then i'll never leave
really quick and jump okay
listen you're not yourself when you're
hungry
that's great your dreams are always the
best
oh my god again oh wait no i needed this
here
dreaming of who me you shouldn't have
you're so sweet
made of hunger yeah i get you
you're just so hungry i get it
you know i get it sometimes you're just
hungry
[Applause]
good question you know it's hard to say
okay cool yeah that's real cool but i'm
on the way
out my dude oh maybe not i thought this
was the way up
yes that's me
what are you doing you think you're the
[Laughter]
skype
i have no idea where i'm going i'm so
lost i i've lost every point of
reference that i had
uh seems like uh mr
hunger uh may know this place a little
bit better than
i do oh
yeah that's a problem
no oh out i'll wait for you
i can wait how much time do you have
hi you're weird and
smell bad your teeth are
horrible you should brush after meals of
eating my friends
anywho um
well where am i what am i doing okay all
right this seems like an apt
place to pause right before we do
something down here and then have to go
through the maze again so thank you
everybody so much for watching
this has been amnesia rebirth in case
you forgot what you're watching
if you want to see more games like this
there's a link in the description to the
very first amnesia of the dark descent
you won't even see me
i don't even have face cam then but
there's baby mark
from 2012. go check it out linked in the
description
thank you and as always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]